[Musica]
voglio raccontarvi come perché mi sono
appassionato la demografia
la demografia lo studio delle
statistiche che descrivono le
popolazioni umane e la loro evoluzione
ma partiamo dall'inizio
sono un analista dati e lavora al centro
comune di ricerca della commissione
europea il mio lavoro è quello di
raccogliere dati da fonti diverse
organizzarli strutturarli ed analizzarli
per ricavarne informazioni utili a
supportare le politiche europee
ho iniziato lavorando sulle migrazioni e
quando mi hanno detto che il focus delle
mie ricerche se sarebbe dovuto spostare
dalle migrazioni alla demografia sono
stato un pò scettico anzi a dirla tutta
ho proprio pensato che mi sarei annoiato
poi però è successo qualcosa
ho iniziato a lavorare con esperti di
statistica demografia e mercato del
lavoro
abbiamo analizzato serie di dati
principalmente di eurostat l'ufficio
statistico dell'unione europea
abbiamo studiato il cambiamento
demografico nei paesi e nelle regioni
dell'unione europea
e analizzato le possibili connessioni
tra questo cambiamento e fenomeni come
lo spopolamento
la disoccupazione e lo sviluppo
economico ma anche con fattori come il
contesto abitativo il livello di
vocazione
abbiamo anche creato una piattaforma
dove visualizzare questo cambiamento e
poterlo analizzare
e quello che ho capito è che i dati
demografici possono servire e devono
servire per comprendere anticipare
quella che insieme alla transizione
ecologica e alla digitalizzazione e la
terza trasformazione che sta plasmando
il futuro dell'europa ovvero il
cambiamento demografico
sì ma cosa sono demografia e cambiamento
demografico
per me la demografia va ben oltre lo
studio della struttura della popolazione
umana è il mio passato il mio presente e
il mio futuro
la demografia e la storia della mia vita
ma è anche la storia della vita di
ognuno di voi
infatti le principali componenti
demografiche sono tre natalità mortalità
emigrazione dove la migrazione va intesa
nel senso più ampio di mobilità io ad
esempio sono toscano ma da anni vivo qui
questo vuol dire che mi sono spostato
dal conteggio demografico di pistoia la
città in cui sono nato per spostarmi in
quello di di varese la città in cui vivo
il cambiamento demografico
per me il cambiamento demografico si
riflette direttamente nel confronto con
il mio bisnonno eusebio che è nato quasi
un secolo prima di me
eusebio mio bisnonno paterno ha avuto
cinque figli il primo dei quali quando
aveva 23 anni mentre io ho già 44 anni e
sto ancora cercando di diventare padre
ma la demografia tocca quasi tutti gli
aspetti della nostra vita abbiamo visto
tutti infatti di recente come il
coronavirus ha impattato in modo diverso
sulle differenti fasce d'età della
popolazione
qui vedete un grafico del numero di
morti associate al codec 19 in italia
divisa e per sesso e per fascia d'età
e se ci pensate bene anche le
vaccinazioni
dopo un po di incertezza iniziale sono
state organizzate in base a dati
demografici
potete farvi altri esempi ma il punto è
che la demografia ci riguarda tutti ed è
quindi lecito pensare che anche il
cambiamento demografico sia importante e
che avrà un impatto su molti aspetti del
nostro futuro
dovremo quindi iniziare a interessarsene
tutti di più
viviamo in un paese in un continente che
stanno invecchiando si stima che l'età
media della popolazione dell'unione
europea
passerà da poco più di 44 anni ha 49
anni entro il 2100
anche il numero di anziani crescerà
notevolmente
infatti le proiezioni indicano che il
numero di ultraottantenni sarila da 27 a
64 milioni un aumento del 120 per cento
e nel 2100 ci sarà anche un giovanissimo
in meno ogni 100 abitanti
infatti la percentuale di minori di 15
anni nell'unione scenderà dal 15 al 14
per cento e per l'italia che già oggi è
maglia nera in europa ci sarà almeno un
piccolissimo risvolto positivo dopo
essere scesa all 11 salirà al 12,5 per
cento lasciando l'ultima posizione a
malta
ma perché parliamo del 2100 sembra così
lontano il 2100
parliamo del 2100 perché i bambini di
oggi saranno gli anziani del 2100 ed è
un nostro dovere pensare a come sarà il
loro futuro e come sarà la società in
cui vivranno
se le proiezioni mostrano che l'europa
sta invecchiando le nostre analisi ci
mostrano anche che non lo sta facendo in
maniera uniforme ci sono regioni che
invecchiano di più e più in fretta e se
fino ad oggi sono state le regioni del
sud europa quella di avere una maggiore
percentuale di anziani abbiamo visto che
l'invecchiamento avrà un impatto
maggiore sulle regioni del nord ovest e
soprattutto su quelle dell'est europa
è una cosa simile ma verrà anche le
nostre città
specialmente a quelle di medie
dimensioni che raggiungeranno un livello
di invecchiamento simile a quello delle
aree rurali
ma più che il contesto urbano rurale
abbiamo visto che non è il vero fattore
legato all'invecchiamento e lo
spopolamento
in pratica i paesi le regioni e comuni
che subiranno un maggior spopolamento
saranno anche quelli che invecchieranno
di più
è uno dei motori trainanti dello
spopolamento e l'assenza di opportunità
di lavoro
l'esito dei lavoratori più giovani e
qualificati va a bloccare il ricambio
generazionale e questo determina un
invecchiamento c'è infatti uno stretto
legame tra questi tre fattori
invecchiamento spopolamento e assenza di
opportunità è un processo che si
autoalimenta e gia in corso e sembra
essere inarrestabile
un altro degli effetti
dell'invecchiamento della società e la
diminuzione della percentuale di
popolazione in età lavorativa e il
contestuale aumento delle persone che
raggiungono l'età pensionabile si stima
che questa percentuale è quella di
persone in età lavorativa nell'unione
europea scenderà di ben 9 punti nei
prossimi 80 anni passando da 64 a 55 per
cento
queste sono percentuali ma in termini
assoluti significa che ci sarà una
perdita di 60 milioni di persone in età
lavorativa
praticamente l'intera popolazione
italiana
e quindi se l'invecchiamento ha un
impatto diretto sui servizi sanitari i
servizi sociali i sistemi pensionistici
lo sa anche sull'economia di una certa
regione abbiamo visto infatti che c'è
uno stretto legame tra la struttura
verità della popolazione il prodotto
interno lordo pro capite che è una
misura purché discussa comunemente usata
per indicarne il benessere economico
fin qui abbiamo visto quindi cosa sta
succedendo e cosa succederà in italia e
in europa però gli scienziati non hanno
la sfera di cristallo per vedere nel
futuro le proiezioni demografiche si
basano su modelli molto complessi che a
loro volta sono costruiti su scenari
definiti da un set di ipotesi io vi ho
mostrato quello che eurostat chiama
baseline scenario ovvero lo scenario
base quello di riferimento ma la stessa
eurostat ci fornisce anche differenti
scenari basati su differenti ipotesi
come vedete per ogni scenario
l'evoluzione della popolazione europea
sarà diversa ma c'è un fattore costante
e comune a tutti e sei gli scenari
l'invecchiamento
ma allora cosa dovremmo fare
purtroppo soluzioni miracolose non
esistono
un aumento dell'immigrazione
specialmente nei paesi che invecchiano
più in fretta potrebbe in qualche modo
rallentare la crescita dell'indice di
dipendenza d'età
però abbiamo visto che tra il 2015 e il
2019 solo il 23 per cento delle regioni
europee aveva un influsso netto di
persone in età lavorativa
un'altra possibile soluzione sarebbe
quella di aumentare la partecipazione
delle donne al mercato del lavoro questo
è un punto saldo di sicuro dovremo
partire da qui
oppure
potremmo pensare di lavorare più a lungo
e andare in pensione più tardi
ma siamo davvero tutti pronti a lavorare
di più
una terza soluzione sarebbe quella di
cercare di stimolare la natalità un po
come fanno in francia con bonus bebè
supporto fiscale le famiglie e un
congedo parentale ben pagato oppure come
fanno in germania con la disponibilità
di più asili o di tate che tengono fino
a cinque bambini
ma forse tutto questo potrebbe neanche
che potrebbe anche non bastare
mentre preparavo questo discorso mi sono
imbattuto in una notizia del 31 maggio
la cina sosterrà alle coppie che
vorranno avere il terzo figlio
beh è una notizia storica
dopo anni di politica del figlio unico
sembra che la società cinese stia
cambiando radicalmente
ma se
trascina e con lei molti altri paesi nel
mondo
stanno cercando di contrastare il
cambiamento democratico noi in italia in
europa cosa dovremmo fare
combattere il cambiamento demografico
per invertire la tendenza sembra una
lotta contro i mulini a vento
i dati ci aiutano a comprenderlo
affrontarlo e sfruttarlo per costruire
una società più equa e resiliente che
non lasci indietro nessuno
proviamo ad usare il cambiamento
demografico come una scintilla per
sviluppare più prodotti e servizi ma
soprattutto per rafforzare il ruolo
attivo e positivo di tutte le fasce
d'età
all'interno della nostra società
per fare questo servirà un cambiamento
di mentalità
dovremmo essere tutti più
creativi ed inclusivi ma soprattutto più
audaci e coraggiosi grazie
[Musica]